I guess tonight's a very talented actor
who's the voice of my god so many
characters on The Simpsons including Moe
the bartender and chief Wiggum he also
stars in Brock Meyer which will have its
series finale tomorrow night on IFC
please welcome Hank Azaria Hank how are
you all right Conan hanging in there boy
I didn't realize I there's a dream come
true I didn't realize I had to appear on
a late-night talk show with these stupid
things dangling out of my ears so well
you know part of me suspects that you're
listening to Spotify right now well you
talk to me I am tuning you out as best I
can
I'll try to hang with unlike your
teenage son currently yeah you know it's
really funny I was seeing about this
today I think I met you it's insane but
it might be 30 years ago it was over 30
when did you what season did you start
on the set you were the new guy in
season one I was the first new guy not
in season one but I think I was I don't
even remember I think I was I came in
about three years in or something so was
it about exactly 30 years ago then yeah
and you could not have been nicer to me
and it's amazing I'll tell you this my
son is 14 years old and he's a comedy
fan and one of the ways that we bonded
meaning the first time he really looked
at me with respect was when he saw my
name pop up on a Simpsons episode and
then I thought I'm just kind of look
over and go like well you're not a
complete idiot but it was so funny cuz
he didn't even know you were coming on
the show and two days ago he just
brought up your name and he said do you
know how many voices a friend of his
challenged him to name all the people
you voice on The Simpsons and he started
rattling them off he couldn't get them
all but I guess that's a challenge for
real Simpsons
fanatics is how many voices has Hank Don
what do you mean do you think it's been
it first of all your I guess it's no
surprise that you're raising a real
comedy nerd there but that's another
conversation that was mandatory he's
really good at sports but I broke his
wrist so they yeah you want to
discourage that yeah yeah no son of
Mines gonna be good at sports I don't
know why you were northern England yeah
and that improv but yeah it depends on
how you count like if you go if you look
at some website I have like two hundred
and some-odd right but like most of that
is just one line that I did is my own
voice you know in whatever episode but
for all intents and purposes there's
like thirty to thirty five running
characters that I'll really do every
week but every sound I can make has been
harvested for this show every human
noise that I can make every voice I do
has been used in the last 32 years I was
always impressed with how much you guys
you really put your all into these
people and I think sometimes doing some
of these characters like mo that's tough
that's like shreds your cords
yeah mo yes raspy so if you talk like
this for too long eventually you're
gonna you're gonna shred yourself and
you know screaming then you really gotta
I gotta save the screaming for the end
and you know you're right we do put our
all into it which I learned watching
when we met I was 24 or something right
I learned watching especially dan
Castellaneta and Harry Shearer and how
they committed so fully which I was so
wide out like wow these guys really go
for it they're not embarrassed at all
even though there's a mic and yeah
there's certain voices I saved like
Duffman will blow me out in a second I
have to say again and I actually dread
it like like oh no I'm an Adu today
right it actually does hurt I'm not
complaining this is very good yeah you
you we're not allowed to complain you
know what here's here's an anecdote for
you I once though my voice blows out
rather easy
we have to watch it and I was having a
rough time in my life and I got in a
screaming match with someone like really
no kidding around that was a really bad
right and even worse than that like it's
in my car afterwards and I was like
school it was so upset and I totally
blew out my voice like I really blew it
out and it didn't come back for almost
two weeks and I got really scared like I
couldn't get like beyond here which is
in my line of work a disaster as you
might ask exactly and I actually I
scared myself so bad that I got my vocal
cords insured really I did
you're always like you know you've heard
like Baryshnikov insured his legs yes
pianists insure their fingers it
actually kind of makes sense that you
would insure your vocal cords I did I
mean if you think about what I'm lucky
enough the revenue I'm lucky enough to
bring in from doing the Simpsons I mean
that was a long time ago a lot a lot of
money would have gone by by if I
couldn't make voices anymore is there if
after all these characters and all these
that you've inhabited is there one
that's your personal favorite like it's
just always fun to do the one I love the
most is mullahs he sounds like he's from
Queens and I'm from Queens and I used to
bartend and he currently bought ends
when I enjoy the most hone in life and
his professor Frank and to me it's the
vocal equivalent of a peanut I cannot
stop once I start if I keep going
I simply cannot stop it annoys the log
the doodles out of my wife but I very
much enjoy it yes one of the things I
can
I always tell is you guys do great
improv so many great improv with all the
characters but with Frank I can tell
that you get to throw in the kitchen
sink you know little little things that
you can throw in there yourself know it
amuse you exactly and with each take
I'll add one and I never want to stop
but the first line will be you know
fairly straight for him like hello conan
how i take two will be hello conan how
are you hi Vick
take Ruby hello how are you glow Hyman
blaze and then and I won't want to stop
to buy the NM i bill the monologue that
follows is Lola
hello Conan how are you he said when he
was sitting in tight jeans thing that he
shouldn't be and they'll eventually have
to say enough we got it I'm sure cuz I'd
like to keep going
I know I know those are probably days
where they're like no no seriously you
know recent Jean or whoever were like
we're good and you're like no no I want
to do this for 45 more minutes yeah
something you can't be depressed making
that I think that's what it is it's like
a natural mood elevator if you're down
and you start talking this way it's very
difficult to remain depressed come and
try it at home some day you should try
just doing a something very serious with
that voice like if you've ever asked to
give a eulogy you should get up there
and do it as Frank
uncle Phillip was a delightful man yeah
that would that was sort of the that was
how we kind of created Brock Meyer was
right there's a baseball announcer who
talks like this does if you put this
voice in every circumstance you know
having sex or wasted on drugs or in a
very serious relationship discussing
with his girlfriend is it does it still
sound like this understood because they
still give the count afterwards you know
it's funny because I think younger
people may not know this but I saw it
right away with Brock Meyers that you
are channeling and how I mean it's
changed but that's how you had to sound
in the seventies yeah and you know into
the eighties if you wanted to be in you
know a color announcer or just a a
play-by-play announcer that's how you
had to sound and it wasn't only sports
announcers it was a lot of any
television pitchman right the Ginsu you
know in Japan the hand is a lethal
weapon but this theory does not work on
a tomato
it's the Ginsu in Japan the hand can be
used like a knife
but this method doesn't work with a
tomato that's why we used the Ginsu or
you know Popeil always po peels pocket
fisherman was always this voice selling
you that was like the generic vanilla I
don't know
television voice announcer voice and it
bled into sports and and then Harry
working with Harry Shearer on The
Simpsons who you know his Vin Scully is
so beyond dead-on that you can't tell
the difference between him and yeah well
he we would joke around he pointed out
that baseball announcers can say
anything they like as long as they give
the count afterwards so that was a lot
of the genesis of the brock mayer thing
too is how inappropriate can can you
speak on the air describing your sex
life or your drug use and then you know
as pedro delivers us latter into the
dirt wanna know now is this true I mean
you've had success on just every
platform imaginable but I understand you
sup for quippy i'm nothing on kwibi okay
you know Quimby should go on kwibi
that's why you are right Conan um the
I'm just curious your your mom and this
is very common but your mom somewhat
withholding of praise when it comes to
your career is that or not afraid to be
critical yeah she know she's supportive
in a way she's 92 now so she doesn't get
most of it right um but a lot of it goes
fire but you can imagine my 92 year old
mother watch and Brock Meyer as she
would say come it's not her cup of tea
but she can tell that I seem to be
having a wonderful time
but everything with my mother is it's
just that is the surface it's like like
with Brock Meyer it's like yes I saw the
show very funny very dismiss Barry funny
did you have to wear that jacket was
that necessary
like yeah mom it's the characters
wardrobe alright I was Gargamel in the
in the Smurfs movies yeah yeah I saw it
very funny what's with your piccata
haircut in that thing like mom it's
Gargamel it's not it's not you know
I'm not James Bond voices I'm Nathan
he's he's bald with hair coming out like
this there's nothing I can do about it
but did you have to wear that that
schmata black robe like yes in fact
that's the character of Gardner Mac
picture you yelling at her back as mo I
don't know why just like she sounds like
it's been pointed out that my mother
sounds a little bit like mo how is I
know you and your family are in
isolation as we all are how's everybody
doing you guys holding up okay we're
okay you know everybody gets their turn
to have a like a mini mini breakdown
right I don't know how it is it your
house but it's it's where I would say
we're fine
but then there are moments we realized
we're not supposed to be together
this much exactly yes my my my wife's
pet name for me
which got retired for a long time has
come back into play in this quarantine
time and she lovingly lovingly refers to
me as the grumpy old [ __ ] and that is
he she has made a reappearance
absolutely
are you the grumpy old [ __ ] sometimes
absolutely I'm I have a little bit of a
short fuse and little irritable I was
the kid you know who and your little
league team who if I made a decent play
at third and threw it to you and you
were at first and you and you and you
bobbled it I would go you suck I was
that kid so and that is carried over a
[ __ ] into my adulthood and like for
example like Mario Kart for example has
figured bigger now my son is about to be
11 and we play a lot of the Mario Kart
is one of the things we do duh sure
but I had to put that like when when we
were pregnant with that with sad son I
was going through a little bit of uh of
an edgy time in my life a frankly I was
newly sober I'll say it there there I
said it
good for you thank you yes about I guess
twelve thirteen years ago and a little
edgy and I I think I had crossed
addicted shall we say into videogame
because there I am playing Mario Kart
alone against like online against
teenagers I think mostly in Japan who
knew all the cheat codes and I didn't
and I would get so infuriated Conan
losing to these kids that have been
screaming in wage at the television set
just screaming and my wife was finding
like look I understand you're going
through stuff but once the baby comes I
can't have this in the house I just you
cannot be thinking about what was
happening specifically in it in Mario
Kart it's making you scream you said
they're using a cheat code what's
happening laughs amilia are with the
Mario Kart but there's a thing you can
get which is like the star which is you
become this like rainbow lit up and you
can't you're invulnerable you go twice
as fast as the other racers and nothing
can hurt you and these kids they had a
cheek over they could just call it up at
will so even if I beat them in the race
they would pull up that rainbow thing
and they run right over me and I would I
that in particular with Drive ain't
saying that sorry that's what makes it
beautiful is that something it's
supposed to be beautiful and wonderous
great explosion of rainbows and
marshmallows that makes your Mario Kart
zoom through the air and your screaming
well that's good if you happen your
opponents hated I know I'm still I'm
screaming bloody murder at a rainbow
cart and while Luigi in his rainbow
trail yeah and so I'm flipping out one
day like that
and it comes to me and my fantasy by the
way is to smash the television I won't
just take it and smash the screen of the
TV which would be you know that would be
a lose-lose right so but it came to me
the clouds parted I realized this from
when I can't do this anymore and I took
the the video game console took it
outside into the concrete and I smashed
it into bits itsy-bitsy bits and it was
great it was a win-win III I got it all
out and it ensured that I that I quit
playing and you know I my wife came home
and she
kayuu I'm like I think I have good news
and I showed her the game smashed to
smithereens and she would the terrified
look on her face when yeah that's great
honey congratulations to us and great
here you are 13 years later you know and
all as well you know you didn't I don't
think you've screamed at your son I
think you've I haven't I've got I have
to watch it die for have to be forever
vigilant I get real educate games real
game 7 yeah with this my son can beat me
at Mario Kart now I just have to accept
that you know this is car of getting
older you know I mean part of getting
old and you have to accept it well Brock
Meyer I make sure I get the word out the
Brock Maher series finale airs tomorrow
on IFC and seasons 1 through 3 are
available to binge on Hulu yes Hank you
describe yourself as the the the grumpy
the grumpy [ __ ] but I've never seen
that side of you you're always
incredibly nice to me and to everybody I
know and quick shout out you know my son
is a huge fan of The Simpsons end of
yours particularly loves you and then
the other night we watched quiz show oh
yeah he saw you pop up and it was like
yep and he exists it was just it's great
you've you've done so much great work
you should be I hope you're a very happy
man I am the grumpiness is easing and
the happiness is is increasing as I go
on describe yeah like Frank really nice
talking to you you too Conan yeah take
care
stay well